[Music]
then unscripted excuse me what a [ __ ]
Donald [ __ ] you know it's buddy I'm
wearing it but you look like one
Oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] you Donald [ __ ] let's
continue submitted by all I want for
Christmas is David shut the [ __ ] up
Twitter is upset with the creators of
stranger things but we're unscripted
kissing scene at the end of season two
so do why I got seen the first season of
scene just watch the second one I didn't
watch that for me click on this video
you already know that there should have
been spoilers ok the first three
episodes were really confusing yes I
didn't understand anything and it's kind
of slow to have somebody sit next to me
and explain to me what's going on and
then I enjoyed it yeah so it took me a
while oh you're that annoying guy I was
exactly that guy like why is that person
oh and you know what there's a character
in there that I found out only until
towards the last few episodes was
actually a girl in 11 is it yes yes if
that was a girl and it threw me off
she's my whole mind was bummed because I
doesn't matter
but she still has like she's in that
this yet more any of that yeah it's so
like when I noticed it and I kind of
made a joke about it because there's a
part where she was screaming and I was
like that dude screams like a little
[ __ ] I was like you didn't go through
puberty yet and I was like what's cause
I think all people but we all scream
like little [ __ ] back then yeah
now it's cream like story here at the
end of the season with I'm gonna watch
it someday should I leave have you watch
any of it oh my do you at least watch
giveth her I don't cut oh my god can you
be a content creator it's too late what
are you watching CSI are you just
getting on The Sopranos now come on man
no that's Scoob for all the like Rick
and Morty that's pretty cool yeah but
what Jack horsemen doesn't like animated
though
Oh Jack yeah oh I watched them the one
about the autism oh my god I don't even
know the name the one that Amy Okuda is
in I don't know that friends I still
tried to oh yeah I know what you're
talking about
yeah it was weird I couldn't get past
the first episode okay grandma throws I
gave two episodes and everyone's like oh
you gotta get past you have to history
and then and then ask someone else oh
you got to get past the first three
seasons son like what kind of a show is
this that's like my brother so there's
like this Adam and he told me to watch
she goes it's really good I was like I
didn't like it he goes you got to get
past the first hundred episodes Naruto
if I give you fifty episodes that I'm
not into it because that one was good at
its time when it came out so it's like
if you watch it now and it's like
stories have gotten so much better you
can't get in the first hundred episodes
it's done I'm clearly tired trying to
stall the rest of this article from
being told because I don't want to know
Oh Silicon Valley I watch the look man
it's the last episode of season two but
it's not really that big of a spoiler to
be or not the kiss between two
characters
don't tell me come in it I already know
what they tell me what the head of the
two characters is this new character in
season 2 which her name is max Oh
Sadie's kisses doesn't care she could be
Lucas yes character's name is Lucas yes
they got chemistry Netflix also released
this like behind the scenes look into
the making and beyond stranger thing to
Netflix there there was this discussion
of that kiss the final scene and so I'm
gonna play a clip from that sweet miss
but Twitter saw rape work we're at the
dance obviously we have shot by the kiss
for max yeah and Lucas I was shooting
that into the whole day with extra style
I was like oh my god wait am I gonna
happen is it not and it didn't happen
that day but then the second day of film
and the snowball yeah but you're you
reacted so strongly to this I was just
joking and you just went you were so
freaked out that I was like well I gotta
make her do it yeah that's why I'm
saying it's your fault anyways it's
great I can't imagine without it thank
you yeah people don't know that there's
also two parts to this previous to this
there were the creators the two creators
tougher brothers yes along with the girl
who plays eleven and the guy that plays
Mike mm-hmm and they had a conversation
about this so this is a continuation of
that with a different with the actual
cast members well isn't that the most
important person to talk to though the
cast members there's context behind it
if you see just that you don't get the
whole joke okay so the first part was
everybody was basically egging it on her
because she was so nervous about it so
all the the girl cast members and
everybody were like so are you ready for
the kiss are you ready for the kiss and
then they're talking about how this was
a playful thing between everybody
everyone was
this joke on her right and then this is
the confrontation or like this is the
them talking about it yes baby was
explaining when she went in that Milly
like the loving girl and then max the
character they had just finished their
scene of when they were kissing because
they also kisses yeah and then that's
when they were like oh we just finished
you guys are next like you guys are next
and then that's when Sadie was like what
no we're not doing that well so it was a
joke that turned into reality because
her reaction was like oh my god and
that's the reason why people are pissed
because they're saying like what the
[ __ ] so this is like two grown-ass men
like seeing a female that's
uncomfortable in this car I think that's
the problem though I think it's the
ignorance of filmmaking
well yeah it's the ignorance of the
public that don't understand filmmaking
that where they don't understand the
relationship between the director and
the actors yeah so regardless if the
actors are old young their sexual
preference whatever a kiss is just one
of the notes like if you're looking at a
score for like music that's just one of
the notes in the scene the Wardrobe is
one of the notes in the scene that's
something like was it in the squishy no
it was it wasn't in the script
unscripted right so then people aren't
grabbing on to the fact that it was
unscripted that the director said you
see it was your fault because we saw
your reaction so now I had to make you
do it and so people are like what the
[ __ ] she's 15 a child should not be more
director can make their actors do
whatever they want in their scene when
they're seen it's it's the way that he
was aware yeah people don't know him so
that's an insight conversation like well
it's your fault I had to do it see the
thing is even her reaction though made
it seem like she wasn't that it wasn't
like oh yeah you're right yeah like she
was like okay it was like she seemed if
any exactly this is one of the tweets of
people saying so would you like to read
it
number bros continues that's why I'm
saying it's your fault dude dude the
director and adult man saw that a
teenage girl was uncomfortable with the
situation which made him more eager to
put her in the situation to draw a
parallel it would be like this if the
duffer brother was a conductor and
what's-her-name Phoebe Sadie let's say
she was expected it's it's an improv
scene he's like you know what I know the
really high note makes you really
uncomfortable but I want you to hit it
and I want it but it's not the same
though because I'll play an instrument
and doing something sexual yeah that's
where the contrary I think you could
only discuss things in the scope of that
art so if it's making if you're making
the SEMA hit that note that's making her
feel uncomfortable that's the same thing
as a kiss we're saying the same thing
like oh I imagine this was three years
later like she's 18 and then instead of
kissing and unscripted kissing it's an
unscripted nude scene and then they're
saying like how far can you take it
which even that is still okay like
there's actors that [ __ ] on set but
they're pulling things out of set
context into real life and I think
that's the part that's wrong I think in
any other time this will be fine but
right now with the climate of hope and
that if you put in those variables yeah
that's why people are hypersensitive
about this forced kiss scene that's what
I think it really is yeah because even
with Michael B Jordan right like
Sylvester Stallone said if you want to
be a boxer in my movie I'm gonna have to
knock you the [ __ ] out you know this
right he's like all right I have to do
it because even with concussion yeah
because I in order it's it's this is my
work of art this is my Symphony my
whatever and this is what I need to
happen in my scene so every single
action in a scene is just another note
on the page but I think people are
pulling the notes out but then like
Sylvester Stallone gave him that prep
and then he was saying he agreed to it
yeah who is in this one there wasn't
there was no talk about it first and
then an agreement but it's also the
nature of like an improvisational scene
though no there was talk about it yeah
II heard about it on the first day of
filming occurred and on the second thing
is one she ended up watch it so I
actually come out to talk about yes so
now after this whole controversy thing
she ends up saying that she never
objected to the kid it was just the fact
that those wishes that quote I mean of
course I was nervous because it's the
first kiss right but I never objected to
it or felt pushed into anything
I always felt comfortable with the
duffer Brothers they do the best job and
always create a comfortable space and if
I felt uncomfortable with anything I
wouldn't have done it that's good our
minors if they're on set their parents
are usually around together
not only that you actually have a set
guardian there to make sure everything
goes down and they're very very very
strict yeah so any time a kid feels
somewhat uncomfortable tired sleepy
hungry they're on point with this it's
like an animal Hatter exactly with
animals too you know with cockroaches
that are like that on set yeah if you
bring cockroaches on set there's an
animal handler if you [ __ ] kill a cop
they'll flip the [ __ ] out yeah like it's
like it's like that string and so that's
what I'm saying like in this type of
situation like I saw that clip they
clearly had rapport with each other
that's like set top you know yeah yeah
they've been working together for a
while now yeah so like I think it's just
like outside people looking in and
they're kind of blunt and like Joe said
it's not the right political they should
have been smart about that yeah maybe
that's something that you guys should
just like that political I mean it was
clearly like pre-recorded like when the
season or whatever was over it could
have been sitting on the shelf for like
months
okay year me even maybe even a year and
like they played and it so happened to
be the worst hang and the conversation
right now is like Hollywood taking
advantage of young people yeah I
probably wasn't the smartest thing for
that to be released yeah yeah you're
like [ __ ] we didn't realize it's good
that she came out and I and I defended
it to you I can cleared it up yeah cuz
if she was really smart she'll be like
[ __ ] yeah dude oh yeah I need money the
first probably lightweight offenses like
you're saying like I'm like stupid oh
that's true yeah like all these people
coming to her defense as if she needed
it like that she didn't know what she
was doing yeah cuz that 15 I really knew
what I was a she's actually my she's
actually my favorite actress in season 2
the only really she is the best actress
to me like it do me oh it's so so
natural was that a real real first kiss
or was the first kiss no no not kisses
or actually I don't crystal we like
first kiss in real life were on set
really really cool they're like 12 or 13
I think though she's 15 oh that makes
sense yeah that's that's pretty young
oh they started was everyone else when
was everyone's first kiss the model like
eight seven seven seven damn do you
start extra young bro it was a private
scoreless kiss like a real
yeah a Christian like a real like a real
one it was probably like 13 oh wow I was
a teenager for sure
I don't know late bloomer Oh 17 oh my
god where's any kiss see that's why
that's why people [ __ ] what you do
normally got morals [ __ ] no I'm just
gonna get a girl like me before this I
wish I would have kiss other girls if
they like me I'll try to help you out
bro come on it's cool it was it was
worth it it was worth the wait
no I wasn't sure
[Music]